يا شاطئ البحر ، الأمواج ، الماء ،
الأعشاب البحرية ، الأغنام ، يأكلون
الأعشاب البحرية ، علينا معرفة ذلك
[موسيقى] ،
لذا إليك بعض السياق
لبدء القصة ، نحن في جزيرة مرحبًا بكم
في اسكتلندا تسمى شمال رونالد  Z إنه
بعيد جدًا ولا يمكنك الوصول إلى هنا إلا بالعبّارة
أو الطائرة ، وفي هذه
الجزيرة الصغيرة الخلابة ، يعيش 50 شخصًا فقط
سلالة نادرة جدًا من الأغنام
، تلتقي ورقة الأعشاب البحرية مع Kevin
بالسلطة في كل ما يتعلق بأغنام الأعشاب البحرية
أنا Kevin Woodbridge I '  m
كاتب خياشيم محكمة الأغنام رغبات
العبّارة لجنة الإدارة المنشأة قديمًا
لجميع الأغنام الغارقة في
الجزيرة ، لذلك دعونا نتعلم المزيد عن هذه
الأنواع النادرة
مرحبًا بكم في أغنام الأعشاب البحرية 101 ، هناك
حشد شيفا يأتي للتحدث بشكل جيد ، يمكنك على
الأرجح وضع ألف
منذ ألفي عام ، لم يكن هناك مجمد أصلي
مفتوح ليس Lea لكن هذه
تشعبت في مكانها الفريد الخاص بها
والذي هو مجرد عشب بحري حي ، فهو
أصغر من الأغنام
العادية وجاذبيتها  يمكن أن يكون لونها أسود وأبيض ورماديًا أو
بنيًا ، ويكون الأفواه لها قرون كبيرة مجعدة
وكذلك بعض الإناث ومكانها الوحيد الذي
يمكنك العثور عليهن في العالم في
أوائل القرن التاسع عشر ، حيث تم
استبعادهن ببطء من الثروة أو للحفاظ
على الأراضي الأكثر خصوبة في
نتيجة لذلك ، حُصرت الأغنام على
شاطئ البحر وأجبرت على البقاء على قيد الحياة على
الأعشاب البحرية ، مما أدى إلى تغيير نظامها الهضمي
بمرور الوقت ، مما جعلها واحدة من
اثنتين فقط من الحيوانات في العالم
القادرة على العيش على الأعشاب البحرية
وحدها وهذا الصوف المعروف باسم
تأكد من بقاء الأغنام على الشاطئ الصحيح ،
كيفن نعم ، نعم ، لكنني أعتقد أنه ربما تكون
ابنتي هيذر هي أفضل شخص يمكن
التحدث إليه عن هذا حسنًا ، وخلفي
هيذر هي
الأغنام الأصلية Dyke التي تم بناؤها في عام 1830
إلى الشمال الوردي  يعتبر سطح الأغنام
ضروريًا في التركيب
الجيني للأغنام. مؤلفة بصراحة لديها
حساسية عالية جدًا من النحاس ، لذا
ماتوا من الإفراط في التغذية عن طريق الرعي
على العشب لفترة طويلة جدًا لذلك نحن نحافظ  هم
على الشاطئ والأعشاب البحرية التي تحتوي
على مستويات منخفضة جدًا
من النحاس ، فقد ركزت العلبة بشكل
كبير على الحفاظ
على الأغنام ثم تطويرها عند الغرق ، ومن
الواضح أن نشاط Kooning يأخذ
كل شخص في الجزيرة للخروج
ومطاردة Milankovitch و  أفسدهم
وهكذا أعتقد من نواح كثيرة أنهم
يعرّفون الجزيرة ،
إنها جزء لا يتجزأ من
ثقافة الجزيرة وهذه هي حديقة التراث
التي نحتاج إلى الحفاظ عليها
[الموسيقى]